uh-oh five favorite movies okay hi this  is Amy Schumer for naming my five  favorite movies Jesus's son and that  sounds like really heavy and crazy but  it's like Billy Crudup Denis Leary  Samantha Morton it's so good  personal velocity directed by Rebecca  Miller and that's like vignettes three  women and I just love how shot and I  love Rebecca Miller the movie short cuts  it has all these stars in it and there's  just one really cool scene where Julia  and more blood Rises shirt no underwear  on I love the Royal Tenenbaums  Wes Anderson I can watch that anytime  and just cry laughing the great Muppet  Caper I think I get so much of my  personal sense of humor from the Muppets  and I especially like the great Muppet  Caper just because like seeing Miss  Piggy in London and Lady holiday and  those characters just still make me  laugh so hard